this throwback sitcom sequel is keeping
one controversial element from the
original to some fans there's nothing
funny about bringing back this sitcom
Trope originally created in the 1940s
the laugh track was first made to help
bring an artificial at the theater
experience for radio listeners at home
when TV began to take off in the 50s it
was used to enhance the actual laughs
that came from a live studio audience
and it worked too a study from the
University College London confirmed that
hearing background laughter such as the
chuckles from a pre-recorded laugh track
tricked the brain into thinking bad
jokes are funnier
right now
that's actually hilarious however
towards the end of the 90s early 2000s
popular shows like the Larry Sanders
Show Malcolm in the Middle Arrested
Development and others proved that fans
no longer needed their hands held when
it came to knowing when to laugh now in
the current television landscape laugh
tracks can come off as Antiquated while
the artistic Choice isn't as popular
these days Netflix is knew that 90s show
series brings the laugh track back with
a vengeance the streaming giant recently
debuted the 10 episode first season of
that 90s show for those who don't know
it's linked to the original That 70s
Show with many of the same characters
and actors popping up in this latest
installment however returning actors
aren't the only holdover that fans might
recognize from the original the laugh
track is back and based on comments on
social media following the show's
release some viewers are not happy with
this artificial audience reaction it's a
normal temperature Eric
you've just got that sensitive baby skin
whether it was to enhance live audience
reactions due to poor microphones back
in the day or to replace audiences
altogether the laugh track has been
around for a long time with plenty of
early 90s sitcoms continuing the trend
it seems like it would be a smart choice
to have Netflix's new series that 90s
show use the same background enhancement
however it's clear that there are plenty
of viewers out there who no longer
accept this tactic one Twitter user
didn't seem happy with it at all
commenting just starting that 90s Show
on Netflix OMG this laugh track is so
obnoxious please say it's not going to
be like this the whole show another
declared I'm like five minutes into that
90s show and enough with the laugh track
viewers over on Reddit were also not too
fond of this throwback tactic one wrote
this show reminded me how much laugh
tracks are garbage another wrote also
fire the person who does the laugh
tracks half of the time it's not funny
and I still hear a dumb laugh track I
don't really know how the whole puberty
thing is going for you probably great
despite the negativity there were some
users who totally understood the
reasoning for using the audio with one
commenter writing people who are
complaining about the laugh track
realize the original used a laugh track
right other users echoed a similar
sentiment with one saying I find the
criticisms of the laughter and the
younger cast to be a bit absurd that
show was also filmed in front of a live
studio audience and had audible laughter
throughout as it turns out just like its
predecessor that 90s show was shot in
front of a live studio audience in
Hollywood while the laughs are authentic
so is the use of a laugh track laugh
tracks continued to be popular among
viewers until the 2000s with the sitcom
set in the 90s it would arguably be
inauthentic to debut the series without
some background chuckling at least
that's what some fans think one fan
offered it's a sitcom have you watched a
sitcom without a laugh track it's brutal
really that 90s show isn't the only
modern legacy sequel or reboot that
utilizes a laugh track consider who lose
How I Met Your Father the spin-off
sequel series to cbs's Fan Favorite How
I Met Your Mother just like that 90s
show How I met your father was
criticized for utilizing a laugh track
with many dubbing its use corny and
Antiquated for How I Met Your Father
co-showrunner Isaac aptiker however
bringing the laugh track back was
necessary as it continued the same Vibe
as the original the same can be said for
that 90s show
[Music]